I'm Laurin I write a column for GQ call
to ask a real live lady and I'm here to
answer all the questions you'd feel too
stupid to ask a woman you actually know
dear GQ advice ladies why is every woman
on OkCupid into cupcakes and knitting
and Japanese cartoon characters all of a
sudden was a memo sent to female kind
instructing you all to act 14 it's true
thanks to real-life Morton Salt girl
Zooey Deschanel and her adult size
six-year-old shtick there is an early
episode of the new girl where she's
unable to say the word penis seriously
she stutters on other words like peepee
and petunia I mean so adorbs right yeah
to be fair girls it is fun I'm not
saying women can't experience an
object's sexuality towards a My Little
Pony every now and again and obviously I
get the appeal of cupcakes they're
pretty and they're made out of cake
but I do think it's problematic when a
woman is entirely suspended in bubble
gum adolescence
especially when your boss Google's your
name and discovers your Pinterest page
looks like a junior-high scrapbook hey
check out these lampshades made of Ryan
Gosling pictures anyone seeking out the
kind of woman who uses the word peepee
might as well just make love to Hello
Kitty lunchbox as for your specific
OkCupid dilemma try using the keyword
search type in your superb mature
hobbies like golf or reading or dying of
old age in my sleep surely some equally
mature lady who doesn't keep a bottle of
fairy dust in her medicine cabinet will
turn up soon
you